I have to shave 5 days a week so on the
weekends I don't shave and I remember
dating a girl she had very sensitive
skin so anytime I would kiss her I would
get kind of annoyed cuz she'd be like oh
your beard is so scratchy and I would be
like all right you know what then I
won't kiss you how about that cuz it
felt like a criticism it didn't work out
with that girl the next person I dated
she had the same thing but she was
brilliant because it was like a Friday
and I'd shaved and she comes up and she
goes oh God like it's so sexy when
you're fresh shaved dude I would have
shave three times a day knowing what you
want is really important and then
knowing how to expr exess that to your
partner is really important like you
both just wanted to express the same
thing except one of you did it in a way
that made me instantly defensive and the
other one did it in a way that was like
oh I love this about you